sur la route de Herson une série de
villages entièrement détruit tout le
long de ce qui était il y a quelques
mois encore la ligne de front un
contraste frappant avec l'état de la
capitale régionale en apparence intacte
car les soldats russes se sont retirés
de personnes à l'automne comme ils sont
venus au printemps sans vraiment
combattre
mais les apparences sont trompeurs
le constate chaque fois qu'il en fourcha
bicyclette il doit rester sur ses gardes
en permanence car l'ennemi s'est retiré
mais n'est pas très loin
de ça
[Musique]
en fait si toutes les villes qui est à
la portée de l'artillerie les traces
d'obus partout sur le chemin de l'excès
en sont un rappel constant
depuis leur départ les forces russes
bombardent en permanence la ville Herson
plus de 2000 au but tirer au cours des
quatre derniers mois des attaques aussi
aléatoires que meurtrière comme celle
qui s'est déroulée ici il y a une
dizaine de jours dans cet arrêt de bus
bilan Simore et une douzaine de blessés
pour les résidents de rerson comme
Marina Kuchma prendre le bus c'est
prendre un risque
chaque fois qu'on quitte la maison pour
sombrer au centre-ville on pense aux
dangers à vous tel une bombarde de
l'autre côté de la rivière et ils ont
fait de notre vie un cauchemar
[Musique]
c'est au but par exemple est tombé
devant la maison du Victor lidwak la
semaine dernière
si comme les autres habitants de Kerson
alexis a appris à évaluer le danger
selon le son des explosions
puis pour nous
avant la guerre 300 000 personnes
vivaient à personne il ne reste
aujourd'hui plus que 60 000
irréductibles bien décidés